so i'm coding along just fine then out  of nowhere this error comes up man i  hate programming i know i should have  written a test first but it's too late  now i could try to fix my code but i  have no idea what i'm doing let's just  google it zero results this is bad  really bad i could ask on stack overflow  but i'll probably get downvoted into a  deep depression maybe there's some kind  of udemy course or a hundred second  video about it maybe i should have  gotten that computer science degree  maybe i'm just not cut out for this  nobody likes me why do i even exist wait  a second i think i think it's working  again man i'm a genius i love  programming